beautiful things for he's an artist yeah
he's like a legitimate artist works that
way Jimmy Burke is truly not ambitious
he is he is only interested in feeding
his brain he loved like he listens to a
Stephen West podcast philosophize this
which is my love though that's my time
talking to that guy back in low earth
I'm gonna get him on yeah I gotta get
him on I love he's 29 and he's got such
a command of philosophy but he makes it
so accessible yeah like Jimmy I'll start
his day with philosophize this just
listen gonna get a nugget and then he
goes and works out and plays tennis and
just he's a national treasure because he
only lives to educate himself and make
the world a better place he just makes
people feel good about themselves he's
trying to enjoy life but do you think
you'd want to do it over and over and
over again the exact same life I do he's
he's the happiest he's the closest thing
to a monk I was just with him I I flew
him down to Florida I just gas folks you
want to watch a disastrous we got him
way too high I got him like three or
four heads deep and he doesn't smoke
weed he hadn't eaten
yeah neaten and he was thirsty I don't
think that if eating helps when you're
smoking it I might be wrong does it he
was already low blood sugar and he
hadn't slept we barbecued that dude we
threw him in a Trager grill and set it
to 25 six hours he's forgetting stories
in the middle of the first sentence he's
amazing yeah we [ __ ] him up which is
too bad because he tells some great
stories now the world will forever know
him as the guy who couldn't keep it
together well I remember when he he had
tuberculosis
I called him Jimmy Burke Colossus and he
had tuberculosis or did he got it they
think he got it from his grandfather
when he was three years old and it laid
dormant and they couldn't find it cousin
on the outside of his lung hole yeah I'm
with him in the hospital I've never seen
anything like this I'm with him in the
hospital and he had they thought he had
two things one the disease that killed
Bernie Mac or two the disease killed
Bernie moon he had a disease that
firemen get from 9/11 where lungs
basically turned to sand I mean you know
it's awful so Bernie Mac died of that so
they said you have either a fatal
disease which is that lung disease or
you have lung cancer okay now this was
what he was looking at and I remember he
was just talking to me like this did it
do did it do and joking around oh dude
yeah and I went Bubba I go
you are you've been given like they are
looking at you either being you know
you're dead or dead I don't understand
how you're not even missing a beat and
he goes dude come on I've made peace
with my death a long time ago I live
every day as he comes and he and he was
getting ready for them to come out and
tell him what it was and the doctors you
know you can't help but to love him so
he was there for three weeks and the
doctors finally found that he had
tuberculosis now at this point all the
doctors fell in love with him all of
them they come in and listen to his
stories so the doctor came running and
it goes we found out what you have you
have tuberculosis
I'm Jim Rose I got great know we can
cure that this is [ __ ] great we can
cure that so he went on nine months of
antibiotics nine and he went colorblind
from the other way yeah that's what
happened to him he is now his colour
blind you know
that's the antibiotic stick but hey he's
a hundred percent but I remember I've
never seen anybody face his own death
and be that just monk like about it he's
does he have a good diet yeah
now when he was on the antibiotics they
give him probiotics as well I
he does probiotics he brought his body
right back I mean he is just a beast
he's never stopped working out he's
never stopped eating really well do they
know what he caused his antibiotic
reaction that made him color blind that
currently is a side effect when you take
nine months of a very strong cocktail of
antibiotics mmm
you know and that cured it though nine
months later cured it yeah thank God
there's no way it cures it on its own
well it back in the day you had
consumption and almost you died
eventually but some people would go up
into the mountains and it would it would
tuberculosis can go into remission and
not come out again when you go to the
mountain the idea was we'll go to the
mountains and breathe fresh air and
sometimes you could go into remission
with intima with tuberculosis but
tuberculosis was almost always a death
sentence in long day's journey and
tonight the great play and Nobel Prize
winner Eugene O'Neill his brother had it
and he knew his brother was gonna die
and he just watched his brother
deteriorate it was a like it was like
having AIDS or something you would cough
you'd spit up blood in
you know I think Chopin the great piano
player died of it then why when people
talk about you know when they're their
anti-vaccine or their anti antibiotics
or Western medicine just read forget
every other science don't don't worry
about Big Pharma just pick up a history
book or a piece of literature anything
that's written before 1950 which most
people don't 1960 any classic book and
the one of the central themes is is the
fact that people especially children
Lincoln lost what three of his children
three two fever quote unquote usually
probably diphtheria or something that
came rolling through smallpox was a
[ __ ] it was the biggest killer
forever
Spanish flu of 1918 people live 20
million 20 million billions of people
yeah so if you just forget forget me
just pick up a history book or pick up a
piece of literature it was on a void